yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is a rapid game on the chest
yeah that's new I haven't done any games
on the chest that much and I wanted to
do a little bit more of a rapid chess so
a little bit longer time to talk about
the game so I'm playing 15 minutes plus
a three second increment um you don't
have the pools on the chest so I can
basically tailor-made this according to
what I like and I wanted to have on
something like this 15 minute base time
I think is good and 2 3 second increment
just to avoid the this silly like yeah
when it goes like end games so let's see
what happens in this game I'm playing um
Cole pilaf and he went for Kings Indian
yeah I mean he's giving me the bishop
pair here and I'm happy to take it I
expect him to go e5 now and then I will
play d5 so we have a typical Kings
Indian structure the sea-fowl now opens
up so it seems he still wants to play
with f5 him hmm
yeah I wonder about this is it really a
good idea to do that I mean it's like Oh
Queen to b3 community goes f5 there is
no direct threat and am threatening b7
which is not so easy to cover actually
so I'm trying that recruit b8 I will
just take a 7 and yeah
a clean move to the C file looks wrong
or we can go clean b8 something like
that but that doesn't really fit well
with a kingside expansion that it seems
that that is what he seems to be trying
to do oh so he five means that I could
actually take this out I want him to see
after does he want you can go look b8
and take on between but it's so a nice
position right I really don't see a
drawback would be 8 Quintus e6
I guess I can go to a6 or c6 here or
well a7 it's not totally off whatever I
do if he takes on b2 I have would be one
and he will have to trade a look yeah it
looks good but with my rating he is
based on just a couple of games what I
sometimes do is Yan Yan be chess I
sometimes play rapid games when I'm
doing when I'm teaching so sometimes
basically sit down together with a
student and that plane and I'm basically
doing this what they do now with the
video with the student but in dialogue
so he asked me why did you do that or
these kind of things this is sometimes a
fun way of doing something different in
the lesson it I do that very rarely but
it's something that once in a while is a
good fun thing to do so please f5 so he
wants some count of life and
that's very much understandable 95 is
the most obvious movie and trying to get
to the six you will certainly take on
you for yeah well I can just recapture
yeah we can and then I have six
anti-returned I mean that that must be
better for white but still this
pollution is really really nice and
there are a couple of things that I can
possibly do here can also think about
rebooting the bishop like E to to be 595
is the most obvious move them and it
looks fine
so he more or less has to take okay
media sorry maybe 92 f6 this is actually
something that I should have considered
a little bit more then in the move that
makes sense then he puts more pressure
on li for and still covers d6 interstate
in fact I was cause I was intending to
capture with the bishop but the move
Bishop to reform is also quite
attractive now that's not a bad move his
Knight is hanging he probably has to
play Knight d2 f6 then Bishop e6 check
Bishop e6 check and then it's not bad
it's really not bad on the other hand
just heating is perfectly okay that D to
f6 Bishop f3 and status
just not giving up on here it doesn't
really it doesn't really feel necessary
yeah that was to be expected
so I guess to have three years covering
still covering d5 I don't see other
squares being having much of a point so
the important thing is that the movie
for for black shouldn't help at all
because it gives me the d4 square so 94
2 is 6
actually whatever what I keep forgetting
is that indie chess I can actually do
listen during the game so if they go a 4
here I have 90 46
that is fantastic so pawn to e4 is not
it's not an option really so what am i
doing next the simple thing to do is
just B should be 6m which would be 6 and
take a five it looks very questionable
for black
I don't see a really good opportunity
for him yeah this is some as mentioned
quite dubious because of this this night
hop hmm okay to each one should be four
doesn't make any sense I think and now I
need to trade what you for does is
however it makes my protection of the d5
point little bit less reliable I'm only
protecting it with a queen that it
doesn't have any means at the moment to
increase the pressure on that pawn in
general the pieces on the 8m g7 are not
doing all that much
you
kay goes back to the zone what is the
point
Knight to e5 something to e5 I can
however I can definitely just take d6
here right 96 what is the thing other
than 95 happens okay
okay well my idea was to go 94 anyway I
just wonder if I have something better
here that's possible
Bishop g4 comes into consideration in
some way at the ship to e6 then and 94
looks perfectly perfectly logical yeah
let's go them
yes 95 quid to be 7 or Queen Queen
anywhere than 1996 is fantastic so let's
do it
I don't see much counter play he can
play like 95 and Queen h4 maybe and
there okay
hmm okay so 96 he will take I mean this
is nice but how nice is it actually you
can also take taken f8 sorry I mean rook
c5 pawn takes 96 that's what I'm trying
to say this is definitely not bad it's
actually very good
hey let's let's just have a look at the
alternative there if I go 96 immediately
he takes it and then what
Ponty eggs only six yeah 27 no then he
falls just hanging and defy this Bishop
c5 yeah that is also pretty good even
avoids under pressure
hmm both both look really really good
okay so I do this he has to take I guess
and now I capture and now this efore
pawn is under attack and I thought that
d5 wouldn't work due to Bishop c5 Bishop
c5 loop f6e 7 Queen to b8 probably and
then like Queen d7 that looks rendered
for like
that looks pretty bad the only thing
after Bishop c5 I have a my book is not
protected and so on that could be an
effect can play Queen g5 maybe look you
won I don't see a follow-up no that
doesn't work like d5 Bishop c5 Queen g5
that I play with t1 cannot even move the
rook as the night only aid is also under
under attack so what is he doing Knight
f6 maybe this is something but again
look T one probably
it looks pretty bad at night as six
looks a little bit tougher than g5 okay
so my idea was Bishop c5 attacking the
rook and then like look f6 I wanted to
play E 754
gainst rook f6 I had completely down
that's completely terrible with the seed
you cannot do this no you should see
fire it's just good Queen g5 rook e1 and
his he doesn't have a move really f2 is
covered so there is no Queen age form
you
yeah don't say a decent move if the
route moves basically anyway I have
Queen to d7 and this is terrible you
cannot take my queen as then the e pawn
will go to the 7n promote and if you
play like Queen point 27 play the Queen
somewhere then we should move with
fretting rook c8 and that's curtains
absolutely curtains that field flag I'm
winning I don't see him something from
him I sometimes overlook counter-attacks
but I tried to I looked at them now and
like Queen g5 and so on so here Queen to
d7 this was the move if 7 is also
looking quite good to be honest but yeah
this is a strong move I mean he cannot
straight the Queen I attack his Queen so
we have to move it again
so probably b8 that looks like right b8
and then then I probably have a winning
move Bishop deform looks pretty good
attacking Luke and threatening rook c8
which is even more devastating yeah that
sets at the end of game okay so Bishop
d4 was the move that I was considering
we should be five is also good nothing
like attacking in the night it has no
squares but this is strong let's do it
Luke is detect and rook c8 is the thing
rook c8 the black queen has absolutely
no squares yeah rook c8 is the move on
is there something that that you can do
the dancer name no Knight f6 I have
Queen f7 check I mean amongst others
probably but Queen x7 does win
oh that's actually very true it's
something that I should have considered
more carefully and just quickly check
now I mean it's no problem
a bishop takes g7 I think it does win
because the eight is hanging weight in
seven Group F to Queenie eight Group F 8
check we sell Group F to King age one
probably King j7 we should be five and
that should winner yeah no silly I
should have considered this a bit more
carefully repeat and now I have to move
the King so that the knight is attacked
again
he has only King f7 and then the should
be 5 this is decisive and the night s
nowhere to go some I go to h1 they take
immediately there's Luke Arrangements
I'm good that's a bad bad moment
King at 7:55 is end of game the night of
the TechEd
and any night moves there is queen evade
basically or yet queen i mean yet queen
is evil is easier so Bishop to b5 what's
the move with bloom
he has no check
okay so what is the quickest way to do
it is there a way to Queen to d7 makes a
lot of sense threatening e8 double-check
and it's going to be very difficult to
meet yeah let's do this it's even easier
to then promoting p8 Queen if this is
just too much enter the knight is
attacked so if you move the King now I
just take the knight and then promote I
mean the eight was close enough but this
should should be fine I actually wonder
how I do the MELAS is here on your chest
we'll see what happens
I really have no experience yeah after a
game to analyze when I did this with
students I usually just copy this into a
study and went from there I'll see ya
whatever what's going to happen I mean
okay this game is not over yet so I
shouldn't but I really don't see a reply
[Music]
yeah he resigned so there is an analysis
board yeah let's do it
how does that work does he actually see
that my opponent I don't know I think
you're already left huh well so this is
the nether sport so what happens if I
click on that okay so how does that work
and we have a we have an engine here
okay that's good
I don't and okay let's go all the way
back so if you played this Bishop g4
line in the Kings Indian this is some
this is some playable line it is
slightly maybe slightly now you don't
see that now this is very interesting
I have to I have to figure this out here
depicted how to how to best do that
because the right hand side is now a
little bit difficult I different how
does that how can I do this and you
actually see the lines I probably should
change this a little bit then how I do
the screen is staid wait
No yeah sorry it's a little bit
experimental but this does work yeah you
see the lines him and so and yeah
the bishop g-49 and we played Knight B
to d7 usually um if people play into
that they go with this Knight actually
looks a bit counterintuitive but it
tries to put some pressure on deform
like with knight c6 and v over c v here
white and normally plays rook c1 or
sometimes Nagi one those moves are
theoretically well explored something
like this I think c5 is actually quite
okay for like all right it should be a
slight advantage which under the engine
like this quite a bit for white and I
mean okay I also rather be white here
just I like spades and so on but this is
what normally is applied Knight d7 is a
bit rare because what is usually the
train of thought is that in a situation
like that and black goes e5 that here
why it should be better because like
doesn't have the bishop pair anymore and
it's not so much the pair of Bishop that
the LightSquared Bishop is missing and
this makes f5 counter plays a little bit
less attractive in some cases in light
squares can be weak this is what we saw
in the game and remember the night came
to b6 when the other thing is that
sometimes in the close positions and
we're going to see it seems a little bit
later you like the light squared bishop
to get playing on the kingside yeah you
know to condi 5 this is something that
the engine also wants to do and now a 98
lose again what stock fish here is
suggesting Queen b3 and now the engine
wants to play b6 this is of course a
move on
six that you want to avoid sorry just
just have to clean this up here and
sitting in a in a for camp so M Queen to
be seven is the threat taking upon a be
six is the kind of move you definitely
don't want to play but maybe yeah maybe
you have to the way it it was it was
pretty bad
the drawback here of course is the
weakening of the light square so I think
very likely I would have played we
should be to hear this position try to
do something on those lights where's the
engine one screen c2 and whoops you own
them there are it's it's hard to say and
what the right move order is when I mean
this is I just thought I was done and
then f5 and this is a tricky thing
that's a tricky moment I think f3m
actually the thing is if he closes it
down here with this and goes for this
standard attack he is not going to check
make me all that quickly and
h5g form he likes the light squared
bishop to actually force fuji form and
there already am pretty substantial
weaknesses on the queenside so
objectively speaking why this is
certainly somewhat better in any game
that is not easy to do it it's um from
purely quality position point of view
certainly quite good for white i would
be a bit skeptical about the engine by
the way in those positions the engine
always loves white and the king's indian
evening positions where legs counter
play is already quite substantial yeah a
five played in the game and okay i have
to take em in
it just make sense and kb8 empty to
point B to so OB 1 the engine is
basically agreeing with this play oh I
had to be shifty one just wrapping the
book that was stupid
I was pretty stupid you know yeah I made
a typical mistake I was I had this
planned beforehand yeah and I think I
played this rather quickly I am one
second and today I mean I saw the
forehand that I get to this position
with which is great for white and I
didn't even look a second time we should
detour Bishop d1 of course is better and
netting material but as you see the the
engine evaluation how witnesses the
problem is that I have a huge space
advantage he scored weaknesses a 556
square weaknesses all over the place and
no and five is a necessary move
basically you need to get something
going it cannot just wait until white
collects a 5 and just wins
yeah 95 sorry that was wrong
click 9 to 5 he took it yeah Bishop g4
given us better buy the engine this is
not something that I'm very surprised
about because it's something that looks
very good but I felt I didn't want to do
fancy stuff yeah just keep it simple as
bishop taste before is also pretty good
but this is a strong strong way to play
I mean I saw this position and felt ok
and what exactly is black the next link
but Queen b7 is something that I didn't
fully appreciate
now with rook c8 threatens leg is under
fantastic pressure 98 is the only move
giving blacks a move for the Queen and
then you have like oh it would have been
actually very nice and something like
that is to go here oh and then this oh
my god
that's a nightmare okay the position
also in the game house was very good
yayyy form
has this drawback of the 1946 route
which it's it's already fairly difficult
Bishop g4 is stronger step bad no no
it's also pretty good yeah this is
something that I then I thought about
maybe this is actually right yeah I mean
you don't want to do this and give up
the bishop
but maybe this is still the toughest
toughest resistance taking and this is
got him going here and this is not nice
it's just very good for white yeah here
96 and I was also thinking that this is
very strong I think correctly so but
directly 96 is good as well a cannot
cannot cover all that so in d5 and
Bishop c5 and now Queen d7 g7 also wins
but this is convincing I cannot take it
this and this cannot be stopped so
basically it's only only this more and
now I'm yeah many moves when we should
perform should be seven we should take
g7 the engine already sees a major yeah
because I get on the seventh but this is
of course not bad I actually was a
little bit sloppy here I should have
considered that if you can actually
still kind of play some moves in and
turn but it is winning should be five
and now Queen d7 is a little bit more
decisive than the other moves then so
it's a good example of a king's indian
without the LightSquared bishop being
not really fully satisfactory this this
kind of situation here is just a bit
better for white it's not like black has
to lose their force but it is not what
you want to want to get from the opening
yeah